i scream you scream we all scream for
ice cream
the following table describes the
relationship between the number of
scoops in an ice cream cone represented
by x so this is the number of
number of scoops in an ice cream cone so
that's x and the price of the cone
represented by y i'll do y in purple
write the equation that describes this
relationship
so let's see when x is zero y is zero
when x is one y is one and three fourths
let me write this as an improper
fraction just so i can visualize it
better so this is four fourths plus
three fourths which is equal to
seven fourths when x is two y is three
and one half so let me see if i can
write this in a little bit of a clearer
way so two times three
is six plus one is seven so this is
seven
halves which is the same thing as
fourteen
over four
and then here we have when x is three y
is equal to so five and one fourth if i
would write as an improper fraction four
times five is twenty plus one is twenty
one so this is equal to twenty one
over 4 and then finally if we were to
write this as a as something over 4 this
is equal to 28
over 4. 7 is the same thing as 28 over
4. so you see
that this is a proportional relationship
the ratio between y and x so let me
write this the ratio between y
and x
is always equal to 7 4. notice here y is
7 4 of x here y is 7 fourths of x seven
fourths it's a bigger number or you
could say one and three fourths of x so
let me make that clear so why y over x
is equal to
seven fourths or we can say that y is
always seven fourths of x we could
multiply both sides by x if we like
so if we multiply both sides by x
we get
y
is equal to
is equal to 7 4
7 4
times x and you see it here when
x is 4 7 4 times 4 is 7. when 0 when x
is 0 y is 0. when x is 3 7 4 times 3 is
21 over 4 which is the same thing as 5
and 1 4. so there we go and let me input
it just to make sure we can input it
right so y is equal to 7 4 x
let me get my
so we would just write
we would just write y
is equal to
7 over 4
times x and let's check our answer and
we got it right